- [Voiceover] So we have three
folks: Jenna,Sarah and Bill
and they're keeping track of their weight.
And in particular they're
keeping track of their weight
over a month.
And right over here we
have their weight change
over the month.
So if you take their ending weight
and from that you subtract
their starting weight.
So, let me just write that,
that's your end weight
minus your starting weight.
That's going to be your change
in weight over that month.
And so we have the change in weights here.
So, Jenna's change in weight
is negative three pounds
which means that she lost weight.
Sarah's change in weight
is positive 2 1/2 pounds
which means she gained 2 1/2 pounds.
And then Bill's change in
weight is positive four pounds
which means he gained four
pounds over the month.
So, given that, let's
answer some questions.
Who lost the most weight?
Who had the largest change in weight?
And who had the smallest change in weight?
And I encourage you to pause the video
and try to work through it on your own.
Well let's just plot all of these
on a number line here to
help us think through it,
although some of you might
already have an answer here.
So Jenna's weight change
is negative three pounds.
So that's Jenna right over there.
I'll say J for Jenna.
Sarah's weight change,
and she had a weight gain
is 2 1/2 pounds so
that's right over there.
Positive 2 1/2 pounds for Sarah.
And then finally Bill gained four pounds
so that is Bill right over there.
Now let's answer the
question, who lost the most?
So when we talk about lost,
where we care about directions,
we said hey, who moved most
to the left of zero?
Well Sarah and Bill didn't move
to the left of zero at all.
They gained weight.
That's why they're to the right of zero.
Jenna's the only person who lost anything.
So the person who lost the most is Jenna.
Now who had the largest change?
And if we think about the largest change,
one way to think about it is,
who is the furthest away from zero?
So one way to think about it is,
which of these is the
largest absolute value?
Well the absolute value
here, the absolute value
of negative three is,
and we can just call this
the absolute change,
is just going to be the absolute value.
The absolute value of negative
three is positive three.
Absolute value of 2.5
is 2.5.
Let me make this a little bit clearer.
Absolutue value of four
is just equal to four.
So who had the largest absolute change?
Well Bill had the largest absolute change
and then second place was actually Jenna.
She lost weight, but she
had a pretty big change.
She had a three pound change
although it was a three pound loss.
Bill's was a four pound gain.
But the largest change is definitely Bill.
Now who had the least change?
Well another way to think about it,
this is the least absolute change.
Who changed the least from zero?
Well if you look at here,
Sarah had the smallest absolute change.
Jenna lost weight so the
weight change of Jenna,
she has negative three
vs. Sarah's positive 2.5.
But if we talk about who had
the least change from zero.
If your weight change was zero, that means
you didn't gain or lose weight
from the beginning of the
month to the end of the month.
So who had the least change?
Well that's the least absolute change?
Well, we see that right over here.
2.5 is less than three or four.
So the least change is Sarah.
And we're done.